ونحييكم من جديد تبقى المراه شريان الحياه
النابض ورمزا للعطاء المتدفق في صلاحها
يصلح المجتمع فهي الام والاخت والزوجه
وصديقه وفي يوم المراه العالمي لابد لنا
ان نهنئ انفسنا بوجود كل امراه اثرت في
حياتنا وجعلت من الايام اعيدا لمحيطها اذا
تحتفل المراه في العالم في اليوم المخصص
لتقديرها ولكن الحاله مختلف في ايران
وافغانستان حيث تحيي المراه الايرانيه
عيدها بالتظاهرات ضد قمع النظام واصبح اسم
ماسه اميني بعد وفاتها في حجز شرطه الامن
الاخلاقي في طهران يعتف به في شوق او يعتف
به في شوارع المحافظات الايرانيه في
مناداه الحريه ومؤخرا تطفو قصه التسمم
المتسلسل للفتيات في المظاهرات الاحتجاجيه
الى السطح لتتصدر صفحات وسائل الاعلام
المحليه والدوليه وفي افغانستان نبهت
الامم المتحده اليوم المراه العالمي من ان
افغانستان تحت حكم طالبان اكثر دوله قمعيه
في العالم فالمراه هناك يحرم عليها ارتياد
المدارس ومن الجامعات كذلك بل وحتى من
الخروج من منزلها منفرده وكل ذلك يحدث
بذرائع مختلفه اما اخر ما فاجات به طلبا
النساء من قرارات وصفت بالمجحفه بحقها
فكان الغائها احكام الطلاق قبل سيطرتها
على السلطه مع اجبار المطلقات على العوده
الى ازواجهن مع تجاهل تام لحق المراه في
اختيار اي امر يرتبط بحياتها
[تصفيق]
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من كابول
زينب حكيمه الاستاذه الجامعيه والناشطه في
حقوق المراه اهلا بك من بروكسيل من
السيلاوي الباحثه في الشان الايراني اهلا
بكما واسم حالي ان اهنئ المراه من خلالكما
ولكل المشاهدات بيوم المراه العالميه يوم
نتذكر فيه ايجابيات حضور المراه العمود
الداعم لكل المجتمعات ولكن كذلك نستذكر
فيه ماسي المراه ومن بين مقاس المراه
استاذه منى ما يحدث في افغانستان وما يحدث
كذلك في ايران السؤال المطروح هو لماذا
وكان المراه الحلقه الاضعف عندما تفكر
الانظمه في استهداف مجموعات لا اعلم
الحلقه الاضعف الحلقه الاقوى ولكن عندما
يفكر النظام القمعي في
ايقاف المظاهرات او محاوله ارباك
المجتمعات تستهدف المراه لماذا
بارك لك ايضا يوم العالمي للمراه واحب
اذكر انه حتى في ايران اليوم منعت انه
النساء يحتفلنا بيوم ثامن من مارس هي اخر
مره احتفلوا فيها كانت عام بعد الثوره
الخمينيه من بعدها منعوا قيام باي مظاهره
واحتفاليه بثمانيه مارس بالفعل هكذا كل
دول الاستبداديه ليست جمهوريه الاسلاميه
وطالبان كل دول ايديولوجيه اول ما يريد ان
يثبت
يستخدم جسد المراه يعني فرض ملابس معينه
ليست بالضروره لبس الحجاب بل مثلا نرى في
قضيه تركيا ايران اتاتورك وارضاه خان يعني
الاول مؤسس للسلسله البهلويه ايضا هو صاحب
الحجاب من راس النساء يعني كل هذه الطرق
الاستبداديه في التعامل مع المراه هي
محاوله للتحكم بالمجتمع لا ننسى عندما
ناخذ حقوق من المراه ومع الاسف نزيد عن
حقوق الرجال لذلك ايضا هؤلاء الرجال
يسبحون اداه للتحكم بالمره اجيب مثال مثلا
في الجمهوريه الاسلاميه يمنع على المراه
خروج من البلاد من دون اذن كتبي من الزوج
انه هي مسموح لها عنه خارج ان تسافر خارج
البلاد نحن نعرف انه في تقسيم الارث
المراه تاخذ نصف الرجل لذلك دائما الرجال
لديهم المزيد من الثروات مقابله بالنساء
حق الطلاق حق الاختيار الشريك كل هذه
الامور في النهايه لما نضعف جهه ما ممكن
نحول الجهه الاخرى طريقه لمساعده
الاستبداد انا لا انكر جمله اخيره لولا
رجل الايراني ايضا ما كان متساهم في هذه
القضيه لما وصلنا لهذه المراحل نحن لدينا
مجتمع ذكوري يقبل عدم المساواه استاذه
زينب حتى في افغانستان هناك حديث وهناك
يعني حتى رؤيه طالبان الجديده التي تحاول
يعني تقوم بمجهود بحسب تصريحاتها هي
للانفتاح لمحاوله الانفتاح ولكن تبقى
ويبقى موضوع المراه وكانه عقده حتى انها
حرمتها مؤخرا من الدراسه وهناك حديث عن
امكانيه عوده من عدمه ولكن لماذا هذا
الاستهداف للمراه لماذا المراه تخيف الدخل
الافغاني
تحياتي لكم والضيفتكم
وايضا مشاهدينا الكرام خلوني اهنيكم واهني
جميع نساء العالم باليوم العالمي للمراه
كل عام ونحن نساء العالم بخير شكرا اما
مساله قضيه المراه في افغانستان انا اتحدث
عن مع كل الاسف يعني انا اتحدث عن قضيه
المراه في افغانستان في اليوم العالمي
للمراه ونحن يعني فعلا على وشك الحذف من
من من وجه الحياه يعني بشكل كامل في
افغانستان النساء محرومات من ابسط حقوق
للحقوق الحياتيه لهن يعني الحق التعليم
يعني اولا
حرمنا من حق التعليم الثانوي ثم من حق
تعليم الجامعي ثم من العمل في المراكز
والادارات الحكوميه وبعدها الاعمال في
منظمه منظمات محليه او خارجيه وبعدها من
تحرك داخل البلد او خارجها بدون محرم يعني
وكانه يعني يحاولون حذف المراه تماما من
اي وجود في الحياه العامه ومن اي اختيار
لها في حياتها يعني كيف تختار حياتها وكيف
تعيش حياتها يعني هذا معناه انه حذف شامل
للمراه من جميع نواهي الحياه يعني ولكن
لماذا السيده زينب هذا هو الحال السؤال ما
السبب
السبب الاساسي يعني ربما البعض يقولون ان
السبب سياسي وهذا ايضا رايي يعني نظر لكن
انا برايي كما نرى نحن في افغانستان
وعندنا تاريخ مع ثعلبان من قبل السبب
الاساسي هو العقليه
العقليه والفكر والقراءه الخاصه يعني
القراءه المتشدده والمتطرفه عن الدين عند
طالبان وعند شيوخهم الكبار اصلا يعني فهم
يحملون يعني يريدون تحميل هذا القراءه
الخاصه الوحيده عندهم على جميع شعب
افغانستان وثم يعني يبرون هذا يعني يتهمون
ثقافتنا بان هذا الشيء ياتي من ثقافه
افغانيه
في حال ان هذا هذا شيء ليس حقيقه اذا كان
هذا من ثقافتنا فما اعترضنا عليها يعني
اذا كان هذا من ديننا ما اعترضنا عليها
لكن يعني هذا كله ياتي من هذه العقليه
القبليه الى العقليه المتطرفه القراءه
الخاصه من الدين ويريدون تحميل شيء على
جميع شباب افغانستان
وان كان حتى يعني داخل صفوف طالبان هناك
شخصيات هناك يعني هناك اشخاص يخالفون هذا
الشيء لكن وان لم يصرحوا يعني بهذه
المخالفه ولم يقدروا يعني المصادمه
والمخالفه سريحه كبارهم يعني شيوخ كبارهم
الذين يعني قاعدين في المركز يعني يقررون
كل هذا يعني يقولون بكل هذه القرارات
فهؤلاء الذين يعني في الحكومه من شخصيات
من شخصيات طالبان الذين يخالفون هذا
القرار وايضا هم الذين يتعاملون مع العالم
هم الذين يتفاوضون مع العالم فلا يقدرون
صحيح
ولكن اسمحيلي اتيت على نقطه قلت بانه هذه
الانظمه
تروج لفكره وهي اعتمادها على تفسيرها
للدين ولكن وراء هذا الاعتماد وراء هذا
السبب الظاهري هناك اسباب اخرى خليني انقل
النقطه للاستاذه منى استاذه منى هل هناك
اسباب حقيقيه يعني لما منذ قليل تحدثنا عن
السياسه المراه غير حاضره سياسيا في هذه
الانظمه طيب ما الاسباب الاخرى التي
تستهدف على اثرار المراه او الحقيقيه مش
الظاهريه
[موسيقى]
معنى الحريه كيف نريد من شخص هي بالاساس
بالسجن ان تعلم اولادها الحريه الان
المشكله مع النظام الايراني احد اسباب انه
الان الثوره انطلقت هناك فجوه كبيره بين
عقليه النظام ومصالح النظام وبين مستوى
التعليم في ايران لدينا كل عام مستوى
الدخول لجامعات 60% للنساء 40% للرجال
ولكن عندما نذهب الى السوق العمل نرى
العدد الفجوه جدا كبيره يعني نساء غير
قادرين على العمل بسبب التمييز ايضا هناك
مهن لا يقبلون النساء هذا الكميه من
التعليم اللي جالسه في المنزل وتحس حاله
انه حياتها في هدف يعني لم تفعل شيء
بحياتها بالنهايه تنفجر وهذا الانفجار
اللي سببت هذه الثوب بالنهايه انا اقراها
هي بمصالح للرجال ومصالح
بقت لي بقت لي دقيقتين اسمح لي ان اختمها
بشيء من الايجابيه في كل من ايران من
افغانستان المراه سابدا معك يا استاذه منى
بما انني انهيت سؤال منذ قليل معك المراه
الايرانيه ما هي ابرز مميزاتها ابرز نقاط
قواتها باختصار
البنك كل النساء في العالم انه استطعنا ان
نستمر ونكسر الكثير من الحواجز لا ننسى
قبل 200 عام كان يمنع علينا ان نمارس مهنه
الطب او المحاماه فنحن مستمرين على رقم
6000 من سنوات من القمع التي تمارس ضدنا
نعم استاذه زينب نفس السؤال
الخصوصيه يعني العامه عند جميع نساء
العالم وايضا وهنا في افغانستان ان النساء
لديهن القدره للنهوض يعني
نحن مره بنا تاريخ مع طالبان قبل تقريبا
30 سنه منع منعت المراه من جميع حقوقها
وحرمت من جميع حقوقها وجلست في بيتها وليس
لها اختيار اي شيء ولكن الان نرى يعني بعد
مرور 20 سنه او اكثر ان نرى بان النساء
ليس في نفس لسنا في نفس الحاله التي كنا
في القبل فيا طردنا على هذا الوضع
وتظاهرنا على الوضع
العالم يعني بالوقوف معهن ولم يسكتن الى
اليوم لن نسكت على كل التوقيت هذه الحلقه
اخر هذا
انتهى توقيت هذه الحلقه كل عام والمراه
منتفضه كل عام والمراه مطالبه بحقوقها اود
شكركم الجزيل الشكر من كابلس يناب حكيمه
الاستاذه الجامعيه والناشطه في حقوق
المراه من بروكسيل مناسلاوي الباحثه في
الشان الايراني شكرا جزيلا لكما
السلام عليكم